so there's gonna be a movie based on
Magic the Gathering I have no words
tap me I'm spent I believe has room for
everything but especially for this they
turn transformers and GI Joe into big
movie franchises and now they're
spending all of their mana setting up
movie deals for all of their other
properties talking trucks Stretch
Armstrong monopoly Candyland
and yes Hasbro brought in Simon Kinberg
who worked on the x-men and Fantastic
Four folks to turn magic into a big
blockbuster trilogy by Harry Potter or
Lord of the Rings The Hollywood Reporter
writes of Kinberg will act as the
franchise's engineer or supreme sorcerer
I won't Hollywood Reporter I won't I'm
trying to be open-minded who would have
imagined that a movie based on the
Pirates of the Caribbean ride would be
any good but the track record of movies
based on tabletop games is even worse
than the track record of movies based on
video games battleship Dungeons &
Dragons clue that bodes not well people
and I can't imagine that Hollywood will
actually figure out what makes magic a
great card game because surprise it's
not the back story it's not the fantasy
artwork on the cards that's just a
pretty 12 million people play magic
because of the deep and complex plane
mechanics it's a great card game like
cribbage but play mechanics don't
exactly translate to the cid field
screen plate if Hasbro really wanted to
make a good movie about magic they tell
the lightly fictionalized story of some
brilliant magic player like John Finkel
it opens with a training montage
Toad's this skill many journeys to
tournaments where he tests himself the
utmost may be some evil counterfeiting
outfit price to blackmail our Negro into
longer enough action faint Black Lotus
limited division alpha cards oh this
thing practically writes itself I bet
it'll come with a very weak ending and
if you want the really good limited
edition alpha ending you'll have to
shell out a hundred bucks on eBay lay
your cards on the table what's the most
you've ever spent on a CCG card let me
know in the comments